I want to start with a sincere uh you
are greatness wait I was like a sincere
one of those I I really enjoyed your
work in this
um but being serious you have traveled
the planet promoting this at Comic at
different Comic Cons how happy are you
that the movie is so awesome
I'm as happy as the audience is at all
times Stephen that's that's the rule you
get to be as happy as the audience is
and the audiences that I've been in
watching these movies are ecstatic so I
get to be ecstatic and I'm I'm reveling
in there yeah but being serious you
never know how the movie's actually
going to turn out no no
yeah it's like it's so I'm sure you're
very happy but listen uh we sparked the
Comic-Con and we said that it was like
taking the movie home to me um to me the
in-laws it's like taking the movie home
to meet your parents because these this
is the audience it matters to and so
when you get that reaction it's it
validates everything because you've
spoken to John and Jonathan they're
hugely passionate about this movie
they're players and so they were biting
their nails and it's so touching to me
to see them so happy at how people are
receiving it
um and so genuinely I'll throw sincere
back at you sincerely it is actually
making us all incredibly happy that
people are enjoying this movie because
we worked so hard on it and we were
scared because it's hard to pull off and
it's great to see the people receiving
it one of the things about this is that
I watched this reaction video to the
trailer from these DMS that were um you
know watching it and like breaking it
down and there were so many things they
were pointing out that I actually didn't
realize because there were hardcore
players so there's a lot in this movie
that's going to appeal to players but
even if you haven't played the game was
there something in the film that you
cannot wait for real fans of Dungeons
and Dragons to actually see
um it's hard to pick out specifics uh I
think that we are very very proud of
that dual layeredness that you're
talking about it's a little bit like um
Watching Rugrats back in the day like
this like there would always be like
cartoon jokes and then there's jokes
that you get when you're 20 years older
and go oh wow that's an adult joke
slipped in there I think it's very
similar with the DND stuff I think
there's d d jokes like really kind of
inside baseball jokes maybe the best
example is that bridge scene which is
absolutely an inside joke to DND players
about your Gremlin uh dungeon master
sitting behind their little board going
hahaha you start off the Trap he falls
um but also it's just a straight up
visual prank for every audience member
in the theater and I think it's that too
those two layer jokes do it for me it's
the corps scene you know that's another
grander of DnD moment but it's such a
yeah people are gonna anyway
um you get to actually kick a ton of ass
in this movie and I am curious what was
your reaction when you were reading the
script or when John and Jonathan were
telling me what you were gonna do
because you get to be that ass kicker
you know
um I think it's it's getting to Revel in
being in dega Montoya a little bit you
know it's like I am so much the shiny
chivalrous hero and wanted someone uh
previous to you in the interview pointed
out that the first thing I do in the
movie is save a cat you know I think
that they know full well that they're
winking towards what kind of hero this
is and then immediately subversing that
and playing around with that Trope and I
think getting to do that is what really
turned me on about this character
because the straight up hero is one
thing but then getting to play around
and interrogate what Heroes actually are
is I think what the heart of the movie
really is that's why I kind of let
edgkin go and fly on his own two feet
because if I get it all the heroing for
him there'd be no Heroes Journey for
edkin there'd be no development 100 uh
listen I gotta rap with you but I
believe you're gonna be at the screening
that we're putting on tonight yep so I
will just say plenty of other questions
thank you for doing that and congrats on
the movie thank you very much appreciate
that see you in a bit